字幕: Sachiko Yoneda
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
（拍手）
キャリアウーマン
キャリア官僚
ノンキャリ
キャリアと付く言葉には色々ありますよね
イメージとしては
バリバリ働いている人
といった感じでしょうか
そうなるためには
この仕事につきたかったら
この勉強をして と
大人は子どもに
ただまっすぐ
１つのレールを歩むことを促す
果たしてそれがキャリアの
真意でしょうか
キャリアって一体何でしょう
今日はそのキャリアについて
私の活動を交えてお話しします
私は
学校と企業をつないで
職業講話や
職業体験のコーディネートをしたり
生徒たちが地域で活躍できる場を探したり
夏休みの子ども達が
地域の色々な大人に学ぶ
居場所づくりをしたり
子どもと社会をつなぐ
キャリア教育をこの10年行ってきました
活動を始めた当初
訪れた小学校でこんなことがありました
６年生です
質問してみました
大人になるのが楽しみな人
するとほとんど 手が挙がらなかったんです
え じゃあ不安な人
と聞いたらたくさん手が挙がりました
愕然としました
それって私たち大人のせいかなと思いました
ちょうど６年生ですから
何か夢を発表しなさい
みたいなこともあったのかもしれません
焦っていた という声を聞いたこともあります
大人が楽しそうだったらいいのかな
そんな姿を見せられたらいいのかな と思って
始めたのが
小学校高学年の子たちのための
「お仕事体験わくわくワーク」
という取り組みです
素敵な 写真でしょう
こちらはお仕事体験の
募集チラシに載せた
大人の写真の一部です
チラシを手にした子ども達が
その体験先で本当に働いている
楽しそうに働く大人と
目が合うように
カメラ目線の笑顔の写真を
お願いして撮らせていただいています
実際の体験現場では
子ども達はワクワクと体験を楽しみます
パソコンの修理の会社で
パソコンの中身を見た時の
おぉ という表情
金属加工の工場で
大きな機械で実際に加工している様子
レタスが収穫できたときの嬉しそうな笑顔
壁紙を貼るやり方を教わる真剣な表情
どれもキラキラしています
ただ このお仕事体験わくわくワークは
実はワクワク楽しいばかりではないんです
こんな流れで行っています
体験先は
希望をとって抽選で決めます
それにより
同じ興味の矛先を持つ
違う学校 違う学年の子が
チームになるようにしています
まさにお仕事の配属先や
プロジェクトチームと同じように
多様な子たちが
同じ場所に行くようにしています
ブラジル人学校の子も
参加をするようにしています
そして
親子で参加する
事前研修というのも行っています
子ども達には
なぜ参加を希望したのかっていうことと
全部終わった時にこうなってたらいいな
という理想のゴールを描いてもらいます
チームで顔合わせをして自己紹介
すると 緊張しながらも
子ども達は少し安心します
流れや注意事項の説明以外に
なぜこんなことを始めたのか
という話もさせていただきます
そして
親子で挨拶実習を行います
さあ お父さんお母さんも立ってください
いきますよ と
元気に挨拶の練習をするんです
体験先に子どもを連れて行ったときに
子どもだけ降ろしてブーンと行ってしまう
親御さんを見たときに
もったいないなと思ったからです
保護者がその体験先の
ボランティアスタッフや
お店の方に きちんと挨拶をする姿を
見てほしいなと思ったからです
そして体験
体験もわくわくワークと付いていますが
ワクワクするばかりではありません
楽しいことは実は楽じゃない ということを
身をもって知ってほしいなという思いもあり
表から見える分かりやすくて
楽しそうな仕事 以外に
見えないところで
行われている地味で 面倒で
でも必要な仕事というのも半分入れてください
というふうに体験先の方にお願いをしています
例えばドッグサロンであれば
可愛いワンちゃんのお世話もできるけれど
排泄物の処理や掃除
商品管理
ブログの更新のお手伝いなど
普段のドッグサロンのお仕事を体験するんです
子ども達はお仕事を体験するのであって
お客様ではありません
人として
対面してほしいと思ったので
もてなさないでくださいとお願いをしています
好奇心を満たすこと
も しますけれども
見えない部分を知ってほしいということと
コミュニケーション能力や
前に踏み出す力 やり抜く力
チームワークなどを
育みたいと思ったからです
そして
その体験が終わった後にも
ひと工夫しています
やりっ放しにしないために
考えたのが
子ども達が
お店の方に取材をするという時間を
お店の方にいただいています
ですので 事前研修のときに
インターネットにも
パンフレットにも載っていない
現場に行って見て聞いて
体験したあなた達だから分かることを
探してきて
私たちに教えて という風にお伝えしています
取材では
このお店で一番売れている商品は何ですか
おじさんはどんな気持ちで
パンを作っていますか
お仕事で 一番大切にしていることは何ですか
なぜこの仕事をしようと思ったんですか など
子ども達から直球の質問が飛びます
魅力を拾ってきてね と伝えてあるので
子ども達が自分が魅力だと思ったところを
写真を撮ってきます
取材をされた大人は
仕事と自分を改めて見直す機会になる
襟を正す機会になるとおっしゃってくれます
また 子どもが注目するところを
意外なところだったりするので
自社製品とか自分のお店の商品の
魅力や
課題に気が付く
ことになると言ってくださいます
さあ翌週
振り返りを行います
振り返りは人に教えるアウトプットです
もう一度全員が集まって
チームごとに
ご覧のように
その取材をしてきた内容を
チームで協力して ポスターにして
プレゼンテーションまでします
それにより
自分が体験した以外のところも
知ることができるので学びが広がります
子ども同士の話の方が入ってきますので
そして人に教えるということは
とても効果があります
見る聞く だと20%
体験することで
80%
人に教える ことで90%
学びが定着すると言われています
受け身になりがちな体験を
能動的にするために
人に教えるというところまでを
パッケージにしています
冬のメロンが一番甘いんだよ とか
ここの店長さんは
インターハイで３位で
今もトレーニングしてるんだよ
っていうような
私たち大人が知らないようなことを
たくさん教えてくれます
そんな子ども達の力作のポスターを
一堂に展示をして
できるだけ多くの方に見ていただいた後
お店に届けます
販売促進になったらいいなと思って
店頭に貼ってくださいとお願いをしています
子ども達のアウトプットが
実社会で生きるためです
せっかくやったのですからね
つながりを持つためです
実際に売り上げが上がったという話を
聞いたこともあります
でも子ども達からすると
ゼロからポスターを作り上げるという
この生みの苦しみを伴った
プログラムは
容易な道のりではありません
初めて会った者同士が
お仕事の体験をするだけでも緊張するのに
取材をしてポスターを作って
発表までするんですから
でも 子ども達はやっぱり凄いです
あとは現場の力って凄いです
やり切りますし
自分の言葉でしっかり伝えてくれます
毎年感動します
やりきった後のその表情は
本当にすがすがしいものです
疲れたけれど 達成感のある
心地のいい疲れだ と言った子もいました
そして仲良くなって帰っていきます
保護者の方からは
あんなに堂々と生き生きと発表する息子を
初めて見た
ですとか
その後の生活でも
挨拶を大きな声でするようになった
という声をいただいています
私は
子どもと大人の架け橋になりたいと
という思いから
この活動を始めました
自分自身が子どもの頃
仲良しの子が転校してしまった
というそれだけで
孤独になり
いじめに遭っても誰にも相談できず
何かここから飛び降りちゃったら楽になるかな
なんて
思うような
狭い世界にいました
大人になって上京して
そんな狭い世界では
知り得なかった
幅広い仕事の世界を知り
何だ
見たことのないものには
憧れることができないじゃんと
強く思ったからです
お仕事体験プログラムで
世の中には色々な大人がいる
色々な仕事がある
そして
その仕事には見えない部分があって
そこには
技術や
苦労や
工夫や格好良さが隠れている
ということを子ども達は初めて知ります
子ども達の声です
お仕事は
思ったよりも大変だった
見るとやるでは大違いだった
ひとつの商品に
たくさんの人が関わっていると知った
商品をただ売っているだけだと
思っていたけれど
その商品の知識が
深くて広くてお店の人が凄いと思った
自分たちで取材をして人に教えるということで
自分の経験として蓄積され
今まで見えていたけど 見てなかった
今まで見えなかった
世の中に対して
関心を持ち
少し視野が広がります
まあ 自分ごとになる と言いましょうか
さて
最初に言った
キャリアって
どういうことでしょうという質問を
覚えてらっしゃいますでしょうか
キャリアの語源は
ラテン語で
轍という意味です
轍
そう 後ろにできるものです
僕の前に道はない
僕の後ろに道はできる
詩人 高村光太郎さんの「道程」の一節です
そう 前に
歩き出さなければ
キャリア 轍はできません
目の前の道を歩いていけば
障害物があるし
坂道もある
途中でうろうろして回り道もするし
寄り道もするでしょう
でも それがその人のオリジナルの
轍 キャリアになります
振り返った時に
ああ ここまで歩いてきたんだなと実感できる
途中で転べば
その時は痛いんですけど
それが貴重な経験となり
困るから
動いて 考えるし
助けを求めて また立ち上がるから力になる
その力が これから先の道で
人や自分の役に立つアイテムになる
偶然や出会いが
道を変えることだって多々ある
だから
子ども達にキャリアプランを立てさせて
レールを敷いて
まっすぐ上手に歩かせることが
キャリア教育ではありません
どんな道を進むにしても
必要な
礼儀や やり抜く力など
土台となる力を
親や先生だけでなく社会みんなで
育むことがキャリア教育だと思っています
ですので 大人の皆さん
子ども達が
大人になるのが楽しみだなと
思えるように
自分だけの轍作りができるように
もっと応援をしていきませんか
きっかけや選択肢は見せつつも
そこに障害物があっても
危ない危ない と
取ってしまって力を奪うことをせず
近道をすぐ教えてしまって
考えることを奪ったりせず
本人がどうしたいのか
よく聞いて認めて
共に社会を作る仲間として
学び合い
一緒に歩いていきませんか
（拍手）